if I look tired in this video and or I
look like I have a cold in this video
it's only because I am and I do but
let's put on happy because we have us a
new trailer but it's the first trailer
of the only trailer to Joker that todd
phillips directed joaquin phoenix
starring standalone joker movie called
joker sex i'm gonna put a link to the
trailer below go watch the trailer then
come back here then we'll talk about it
i'll give you a second alright that's
enough time glad you watch the trailer
let's talk about it and I gotta say I've
done videos about this before I mean not
to try other but you know some of the
behind the scenes footage and walking
Phoenix is the first image of him and I
had things I wanted to see in this movie
and those things seemed to be presented
in this trailer this looks like a story
of a working man beaten down by society
who just kind of takes control of
situation by murdering people but that's
I feel like this kind of in us right
like it's in us to root for the working
man but like that's why we were like
yeah Bulger and spider-man homecoming I
get it man you just sir providing for
your family this guy I don't know is
that is that is he providing for his mom
is that his mom that looks like his mom
is it the same lady some hardcore
Oedipus complex [ __ ] happening if it is
this guy really does take the hits
though like when I say society beats him
down I mean I mean I'm sure his
situation sucks but actually physically
beats him down I mean that's a hard hit
right there you know that gets revenge
on those guys like it for nothing else
he needs to get revenge on those guys I
get if they want to make it realistic
the odds of him actually finding those
guys again and getting revenge it's not
likely but if you really want to get us
on the Joker side come on just give us
those kills Joker's the greatest
character ever created he deserves a
little revenge I want to watch this
movie and be like oh man that sucks for
him it's I'm sorry man yeah you got a
clown nose and you're creeping around
kids and making smiles on them which I'm
pretty sure is that Bruce Wayne did he
just put a smile on Bruce Wayne's face
thus setting the stage for events to
come for years if not decades that
actually makes me think now that Thomas
Waynes death is going to be by him at
the very least inspired by him like it
looks like he starts inspiring maniacs
in the city but the most obvious thing I
saw in this trailer that I really liked
it that was posture changes at first
he's walking around he's really dumpy
he's not confident he walks like how you
would think
someone named Arthur Fleck would walk
them by the Andy has confidence he has
grace he's doing like ballet in his
kitchen you see a transformation even
here in the trailer I do see I like that
scene where he's going on stage and he's
kind of like dancing again has more
swagger than he did before I saw someone
in the comment section of that trailer
was like are they gonna do the Dark
Knight Returns thing here nah girl I
didn't hit me until I read that and now
I'm like oh man maybe Dark Knight
Returns if you don't know I read
spoilers for Dark Knight Returns if you
haven't read it he goes on what's pretty
much David Letterman who's drawn like
David Letterman but they can't call him
David Letterman pointers he goes on a
talk show that pretty much as seen here
and the audience just doesn't make it
out alive I'm just saying is that good
that's like that's an iconic Joker
moment in an iconic graphic novel if
they want to do it this would be the
place to do it
I just love us being done with Joker
here like in the end when you see him in
full makeup and the music cues up that's
what Heath Ledger displayed that's
what's on display here it's not the
voice is not the same eNOS it's the
control of the situation the control of
the room if you're a zany as mountain
dew field maniac it doesn't mean you
have control of the room of the
situation hey hey okay is coffee on this
side of the camera okay now Mountain Dew
I'm animal but it's about that control
it's about the intelligence because the
Joker is very smart
that's what Jared Leto was missing if I
feel bad for Jared Leto honestly if you
look at it as a business he got a job
you want to do a good job at the job and
didn't do a good job
I'm just saying Jared Leto is sandwiched
in between Heath Ledger's Joker and now
Hawking phoenixes Joker if Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker looks as good as it
looks here or Jared Leto no one wants to
be in the middle of that sandwich - this
handsome
I mean this [ __ ] night and day if he
pulls it off I love people I feel like
he'll pull it off this one I'm gonna go
ahead and take the leap of light dude
it's it's the guys filmography it's the
performances have you seen her he wants
to [ __ ] a phone and he makes it work
this is one of the great actors working
today and he's the Joker my hang-up in
this whole thing isn't actually it's not
walking Phoenix it's the script which
walking Phoenix says he likes of and
I'll take its word for it but really
it's Todd Phillips Todd Phillips isn't
known for bringing the character depth
that AI would want in a movie like this
and B this trailer looks like it's gonna
have so my real hang-up is like all the
guy who directed all the hangover movies
the first hangover is great the other
two not as much I mean war dogs it's
probably the most character driven one
so Todd Phillips is my hang-up but this
trailer makes me go still still that is
a great moment when he walks in didn't
full makeup I mean I'm not gonna like
when you saw the picture of him and
makeup I was like I was probably pre
Joker but no that's that's his Joker
makeup but he owns it he makes that [ __ ]
work he makes it look terrifying even
throws back to John Wayne Gacy
absolutely you can see the parallel that
which makes this even creepier so this
is a great teaser trailer this trailer
showed me what I'm hoping the movie
actually has hope it's not like a
well-constructed trailer and say yeah
the movies just not that deep at all
that would actually that would bum me
out that would sadden me to an insane
degree it's not gonna do another
standalone Joker movie like this if this
doesn't work I love that DC's they're
making the right calls man took him a
few years but they're here now and the
Joker come on is the greatest character
ever made he just is I mean this to me
you may disagree but it is I mean in my
opinion but it you don't have to agree
but he is yeah I think he's gonna bring
it I hope Todd Phillips does too where's
our the first official trailer - Joker
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and I just did a
review for Shazam like less than a day
ago less than half a day ago I feel like
now that did this so close to it if you
like the algorithms gonna bury it so if
you haven't seen my review for Shazam
I'll put a link below if you can check
that out I would appreciate it I know
how you work YouTube you'll work to [ __ ]
us and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]